es wird ihnen denn jetzt im konkreten im
aktuellen fall vorgeworfen
ja wir haben die lange skandal akte von
prinz ernst august in den letzten 20
jahren schon gehört jetzt in der
aktuellen causa sind sieben neue
vorwürfe machen also gefährliche
körperverletzung nötigung
sachbeschädigung widerstand gegen die
staatsgewalt und das ist ja auch
gekommen durch diesen einsatz gestern
morgen auf seinem eigenen anwesen wo er
zwei angestellte von ihm letztlich
bedroht haben soll
und das hat ihm nun hier diese
einweisung in das die justizanstalt wels
eingebracht dass ein über 100 jahre
altes gebäude die passage vorne vom
landesgericht wirkt etwas
herrschaftlicher als es eigentlich ist
er ist hier eingesperrt mit etwa 160
häftlingen meist untersuchungshäftlinge
die bis zu 18 monate oder bis zu 18
monate strafhaft auch hier verbüßen
können und ihm selbst wenn er denn
morgen von der untersuchungsrichterin
hier in haft genommen werden sollte
drohen für diese vorfälle jetzt das wird
alles zusammen angeklagt hat mir ein
sprecher der staatsanwaltschaft gesagt
ihm drohen bis zu drei jahre haft
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren